Hast du eine Kettensäge?
Dann kann ich das hier
auseinandersägen.
Wie sagt man "Kettensäge"
auf Spanisch?
Sierra de cadena.
- Sierra de cadena.
Si.
- I'm gonna look for one.
Donde esta sierra de cadena?
* Una cadena? *
* Unverständliche Frage
auf Spanisch *
No, I mean a ...
* Kettensägengeräusch *
No, I need a chain saw.
I need ...
* Kettensägengeräusch *
No tenemos eso.
Mein Name ist Arthur Honegger. Acht
Jahre waren die USA mein Zuhause.
Arthur Honegger in New York ...
Als Korrespondent kam ich
in dieser Zeit ganz schön herum:
47 von 50 Bundesstaaten
habe ich besucht.
Auch heute noch beschäftigt mich
dieses grosse, verrückte Land
praktisch nonstop
bei meiner Fernseharbeit.
In dieser Serie will ich nun
mein unbekanntes Amerika entdecken,
abseits der grossen Politik:
neue Staaten,
neue Menschen, neue Erfahrungen.
This is my paradise.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
In Puerto Rico
gibt es ein Davor und ein Danach.
Vor September 2017,
vor Hurrikan Maria, und danach.
Neun Monate ist der Sturm her,
als ich meinen Fuss zum ersten Mal
auf die Insel setze.
Ja, das könnte sie sein.
Ich habe mich mit Lisa Ladner
verabredet.
Sie lebt seit zwei Jahren hier,
ist halb Puerto Ricanerin,
halb Schweizerin.
Guten Morgen.
- Hallo.
Lisa? Hallo.
- Hallo, Arthur.
Lisa ist Schweizer Honorarkonsulin
in Puerto Rico.
Sie kennt sich aus, weiss auch,
wo ich mit anpacken kann
beim Wiederaufbau.
Denn die Wunden, die der Sturm
diesem Paradies zugefügt hat,
sind längst nicht verheilt.
Ich habe etwas gesucht, wo bisher
noch nicht viel gemacht wurde.
Und habe das Theater in Loiza in
totalem Schockzustand angetroffen.
Es ist so zerstört, dass bis jetzt
noch niemand die Kraft gefunden hat,
etwas zu machen.
Wirklich in Schockstarre.
Ihr werdet sehen.
* Sanftes, treibendes Glockenspiel *
Puerto Rico ist ein Territorium
der USA in der Karibik.
Hurrikan Maria
tötete über 3'000 Menschen
und zerstörte unzählige Häuser.
Ein Sturm der Kategorie 5 -
weiter geht die Skala gar nicht.
Es gibt nach wie vor
Gegenden ohne Strom.
Es gibt noch viele Schwierigkeiten
bei der sauberen Wasserversorgung.
Noch immer gibt es -
ich weiss die genaue Zahl nicht -
Zehntausende improvisierte Dächer
mit blauen Plastikplanen.
* Nachdenkliche, treibende Musik *
Links ist das Theatergebäude.
Der Zaun ist eingestürzt.
Ein Baum fiel drauf.
Es sieht aus, als hätte der Sturm ...
- ... erst gerade gewütet. Genau.
Wir wollen nicht einfach
über die Misere berichten -
wir wollen mit anpacken.
Mal sehen,
wie weit wir in einer Woche kommen.
Das Kinder- und Jugendtheater
Flor de Cahillo
zog früher mit dieser fahrbaren Bühne
durch die Dörfer der Insel.
Seit ein paar Jahren hatte es auch
einen festen Platz, hier in Loiza.
Jetzt ist alles zerstört.
Ist das die Dame?
- Das ist Zora.
Zora.
Willkommen im Kulturzentrum
von Loiza.
Zora Moreno hat das Theater
vor 36 Jahren gegründet.
Es ist ihr Lebenswerk,
das hier in Trümmern liegt.
Die Stadträtin kommt von hinten.
Buenas tardes.
- Tardes? Already?
Yes, afternoon.
- It's afternoon, okay.
Nice to meet you. I'm Arthur.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Julia.
Ich bin die Bürgermeisterin
dieser wundervollen Stadt.
This is Lisa Röösli, the producer.
- Hello.
Das war der Raum,
wo wir geprobt haben.
Theater, Tanz, alles.
Julia, pass auf, lauf nur am Rand!
Oh, oh. Es peligroso.
Dangerous.
- Ja, es ist gefährlich.
Ay, ay, ay!
- Are you okay?
150 Kinder und Jugendliche
haben hier getanzt und gelacht,
Musik und Theater gemacht.
Dann kam der Sturm.
Y aunque ... Sorry.
Wenn so etwas passiert,
dann geht das ganz tief.
In mir drin brennt ein Feuer dafür,
junge Menschen zu unterstützen.
Ich bin selbst
in armen Verhältnissen aufgewachsen.
Und so ist dieses Bedürfnis
entstanden, mich zu bilden -
nicht nur für mich selbst,
sondern auch für andere,
damit ich ihnen etwas anbieten kann.
Die Kinder
sollen die Möglichkeit haben,
aufzusteigen
und ihr Glück zu finden.
Siehe da:
Zora hat sogar eine Kostprobe
ihres Schaffens für uns vorbereitet.
Hola.
- Das ist mein Herzchen.
Was hast du gelernt?
- Ballett.
* Instruktionen auf Spanisch *
Muy bien!
* Applaus *
* Zauberhafte Klänge *
Zora erzählt mir, ihr Theater sei
der erste Ort auf der Insel gewesen,
an dem schwarze Kinder
ins Ballet gehen konnten.
* Applaus *
Que linda!
Dass jetzt
die Bürgermeisterin hier ist,
hat wohl nicht zuletzt
auch mit unserer Kamera zu tun.
So, Julia.
Was braucht es hier, damit es
wieder aufgebaut werden kann?
Wir brauchen Geld.
Wir haben 737 Häuser
mit blauen Plastikdächern.
Das ist im Moment unsere Priorität.
Ja, die Leute
brauchen ein Dach über dem Kopf.
Wir werden ihr etwas Geld geben.
Aber es reicht nicht.
Wir sind eine arme Gemeinde.
Das Theater
hat eine grosse Bedeutung hier, oder?
Ja, wir haben Probleme
mit dem Zusammenhalt.
Zora hat einen grossen Beitrag
geleistet,
dass Beziehungen unter den Kindern
aus verschiedenen Milieus entstehen.
Sie macht wichtige Sozialarbeit.
Zorita!
Du bist nicht allein.
Wir sind bei dir.
Ich glaube dir.
- Yes.
Solche Versprechen
hat Zora schon öfter gehört.
Vielleicht folgen ja mit unserer
Anwesenheit jetzt auch Taten.
Die Bürgermeisterin jedenfalls will
morgen Gemeindearbeiter schicken.
Ob sie auch Geld bereitstellt -
da bin ich mal gespannt.
* Verträumte Gitarrenmelodie *
Heute passiert hier
aber gar nichts mehr.
Es ist nämlich Sonntag,
Zeit für den Gottesdienst.
Auch da will Zora Verbündete suchen,
und wir kommen mit.
Auf dem Weg zur Kirche
beginne ich zu verstehen,
warum sich Puerto Rico
auch die Insel des Charmes nennt.
Da kommen die Leute auch hin?
- Da kommen sie hin.
Sie parkieren halt querfeldein
oder kommen mit den Velos.
Dann wird hier gebadet
oder gepicknickt.
Barbecue kommt
vom karibisch-indianischen Barbakoa.
Das ist ein Erdloch,
das man mit Kohle füllt
und dann das Fleisch drauflegt.
Barbecue und Pina Colada -
alles von hier?
Alles von hier, genau.
Uracan
kommt aus dem Taino-Indianischen.
Hamaka - hammock.
Alle drei zusammen
ergeben einen guten Tag.
* Latino-Musik aus dem Hintergrund *
Pelikane.
Da hinten sieht man sie fliegen.
Schön.
Uuund jetzt ...
- Ui, ui, ui.
Oh! Aber so. Und dann drop it!
- Sie stürzen runter.
Senkrecht hinein.
Das ist sehr typisch: Menschen
mit Drinks in der Hand im Wasser.
Da hat man keine Lust zu arbeiten.
- (Lachend) Nein.
Du kannst dich
immer noch umentscheiden.
Beachlife, Cocktails, Partys -
dafür ist Puerto Rico bekannt.
Hurrikan Maria hat aber auch
den Tourismus schwer beschädigt -
er hat sich bis heute
nicht ganz erholt.
Immerhin: Der historische Kern
der Hauptstadt San Juan
wird seiner glanzvollen Geschichte
gerecht,
und so legen
auch Kreuzfahrtschiffe wieder an.
Sie bringen die Touristen zurück,
die dieses Stück Weltkulturerbe
mit eigenen Augen sehen wollen.
Kolumbus besetzte die Insel einst
im Namen der spanischen Krone.
Erst Ende des 19. Jh. wurde
die Kolonie Teil der USA - irgendwie.
Denn Puerto Rico
ist kein eigener Bundesstaat,
sondern ein assoziiertes Territorium.
Das bedeutet, dass die Puerto Ricaner
zwar einen US-Pass haben,
aber nicht mitbestimmen können,
wer im Kongress
oder im Weissen Haus sitzt.
Hier bereiten sie
das Foodfestival vor,
um nach dem Gottesdienst zu feiern.
Einmal im Jahr
wird kräftig gegessen.
Einmal im Jahr?
- Das ist Tradition, seit 40 Jahren.
Das ist heute?
- Ja.
Heute wird kräftig gegessen?
Wir sind am richtigen Tag gekommen.
Er ist der Pastor dieser Kirche.
- Sprechen Sie Spanisch?
Nein, Englisch.
Ich bin Arthur. Freut mich.
Pastor Sustache.
Sie sehen aus wie George Clooney.
Ich bin nicht der Erste,
der das sagt, oder?
Das ist zu viel der Ehre.
Wir haben karibische Musik für Sie.
Really? Okay. Ich freue mich drauf.
* Treibende, helle Klänge *
* Fröhliche Musik mit einer Vielzahl
Instrumenten und spanischem Gesang *
Für die, die mich nicht kennen:
Ich bin Zora Morena.
Ich bin seit 26 Jahren in Loiza und
wohne im Quartier Santiago del Mar.
Meine Tochter Roisa
ist in dieser Kirche getauft worden.
Diese Gruppe von Freunden aus
der Schweiz ist nach Loiza gekommen,
weil das Kulturzentrum von Loiza von
Hurrikan Maria zerstört worden ist.
Muy bien, muy bien.
Wenn ihr jemanden kennt, der helfen
kann: Wir machen alles für Loiza.
Toll, damit bin ich hier jetzt
bekannt wie ein bunter Hund -
beim Kulturzentrum
muss jetzt wirklich was gehen.
Die Hoffnung jedenfalls
ist mit Händen zu greifen.
Oder besser gesagt,
mit Armen zu umschliessen.
Man herzt sich hier gern.
Und man kocht füreinander -
immer genug, versteht sich.
Die traditionelle Küche
ist ein Mischmasch der Kulturen:
Indianisch, afrikanisch, spanisch,
in Puerto Rico kommt alles zusammen.
Amerikanisch sind hier heute
nur die Hygienevorschriften.
(Frau) That's the rice one.
Do you like it?
Und dann lerne ich noch ein Theater-
talent aus Zoras Ensemble kennen:
den kleinen Alex.
Ich hab den Guancho gespielt.
Guancho ist der Hauptdarsteller
eines Stückes.
Ah, du warst der Star?
That's nice.
Der Broadway wartet.
Zora Moreno hat das Stück von Guancho
vor mehr als 30 Jahren geschrieben.
Es ist auf der ganzen Insel bekannt.
* Die Frau singt auf Spanisch. *
Wendy ist die Mutter von Alex.
Sie erzählt mir, dass das Stück
rund um Guancho und seine Familie
gerade wieder sehr aktuell ist.
Das Thema des Stückes: Der Vater
hat kein Geld, findet keinen Job,
es gibt kein Auskommen
in Puerto Rico.
Er entscheidet sich,
in die USA zu gehen,
weil er da Verwandte hat.
Die Kinder
bleiben bei den Grosseltern zurück.
Mit dem Wirbelsturm Maria
ist das heute
wieder eine ähnliche Situation.
Weil viele Leute
nach dem Sturm weg gingen.
Viele Familien möchten
gar nicht weg, aber sie müssen.
Sie sie lassen alles zurück,
um in die USA zu gehen.
Heute leben 3,3 Mio.
Puerto Ricaner in ihrer Heimat.
In den USA leben weit über 5 Mio.
Die Wirtschaft auf der Insel
liegt allerdings nicht erst
seit dem Hurrikan am Boden:
Vor Maria kam der Finanzsturm -
und jetzt ist Puerto Rico pleite.
Oft lässt sich nicht genau sagen,
was die Häuser hier
mehr beschädigt hat:
die Naturkatastrophe
oder die Misswirtschaft.
Nicht wenige sehen die Schuld
auch in Washington.
Der Zugang zu den Handelshäfen etwa
ist nur amerikanischen Frachtern
gestattet,
Steuergeschenke für Grosskonzerne
waren jahrzehntelang üblich,
und seit ein paar Jahren
kontrollieren die USA
sogar das Budget vollständig.
Ich merke schnell: Der Streit
über den Status von Puerto Rico
ist  d a s  politische Thema hier.
* Düstere Klänge *
* Er spricht Spanisch. *
Montagmorgen, die Arbeit ruft.
Wir wollen eine Abkürzung zum Theater
nehmen - und ich lerne:
Abseits der Hauptstrasse wird's hier
schnell abenteuerlich.
Gracias. Igualmente.
Was hat er gesagt?
- Ich müsse unter der Brücke durch.
Aber da sind wir gerade hergekommen.
Ja, aber ich müsse
unter der Brücke durch.
Die Brücke,
die so halb zusammengefallen ist.
Okay. Vielleicht hat jeder
seinen eigenen Weg nach Loiza.
Wasser auf der Strasse -
ein Rohrbruch.
Vielleicht eine Folge des Sturms,
vielleicht einfach nur
zerfallende Infrastruktur,
so genau weiss das niemand hier.
Riecht gut hier.
Also Geruchsfernsehen
gibt's ja nicht.
Aber es riecht etwas streng.
Nach Schwefel? - Ja.
50 Min. statt 45.
Die Maschine ist schon da.
Ich glaube, den wichtigsten Teil
haben wir noch nicht verpasst.
Auf einer Baustelle heisst das:
Im Kreis stehen und besprechen,
was gemacht werden muss.
Ein halbes Dutzend Arbeiter
stehen bereit,
die Bürgermeisterin
hat Wort gehalten.
Wir nehmen diese Sachen hier
also weg?
Ich spreche kein Englisch.
Zora, wie geht es dir?
Okay, thank you.
Hola!
Guten Tag!
- Placer.
Gehören Sie auch zum Theater?
Ich habe das Team von der Stadt
hergebracht.
Vielen Dank, dass Sie hier sind.
Es sieht gut aus.
Er ist auch Tänzer.
Tanzen statt im Kreis stehen -
hier geht's anders zu und her
als auf europäischen Baustellen,
das ist schon mal klar.
Kann ich da draussen was machen?
Willst du anfangen?
- Ja, ich möchte anfangen.
* Der Bagger piepst. *
No, don't stop!
Sie können machen, was sie wollen.
Wir wollen nur helfen.
Wo können wir helfen?
He can continue?
- Er kann einfach weitermachen.
But we are just gonna ...
... do stuff.
Ich fange jetzt mal an,
hier auszureissen.
Irgendwas muss man ja tun.
Alles
erst seit dem Hurrikan gewachsen.
Krass.
Dann taucht zum Glück David auf,
ein Freund von Zora.
I take these out? Yeah.
Der weiss, was zu tun ist,
das merke ich sofort.
Das ist wie Karton.
- Ja.
Das ganze Sperrholz kommt raus?
- Ja. Alles Sperrholz.
Lisa, habt ihr das nach dem Hurrikan
die ganze Zeit gemacht?
So hat es ausgesehen, genau.
Alle mit Handschuhen am Aufräumen.
Zum Glück gab es immer etwas Hilfe.
So habt ihr Wochen, Monate verbracht?
- Immer noch.
So wie wir jetzt aufräumen,
tun das noch zig Tausende Haushalte.
Neun Monate lang
stand hier die Zeit still -
jetzt kommt Bewegung in die Sache.
Unsere Ankunft
hat da offenbar etwas ausgelöst.
* Gefühlvoller Latin-Pop: "Despacito"
von Luis Fonsi *
# Si, sabes que ya llevo un rato
mirandote.
# Tengo que bailar contigo hoy.
# Vi que tu mirada
ya estaba llamandome.
Neben Zora, David und den Arbeitern
sind auch Freiwillige vor Ort:
Leute, die im Theater
gearbeitet haben
und Jugendliche,
die hier auf der Bühne standen.
Zusammen arbeiten wir
am Neuanfang für Flor de Cahillo.
Arturo.
- Yes?
Ich probiere es mal mit Englisch.
- Okay, tell me.
I want to adopt you.
Du willst mich adoptieren?
Ist das okay für deine Familie?
Meine Mutter ist vielleicht froh,
wenn du mich ihr abnimmst.
Danke, Arthur.
- Yes.
Despacito. Dabei weiss ich nicht mal,
was das heisst.
Langsam.
- Okay.
Nach Hurrikan Maria
konnte ich drei Wochen lang
nicht mit meiner Familie sprechen.
Ich hatte keinen Kontakt
zu meinem Vater, meiner Mutter
oder meinem Bruder.
Also wusstest du nicht, wo sie waren?
Nein, die Telefonmasten waren weg.
- Schrecklich.
Du warst damals in den Staaten?
- Ja, ich habe dort gearbeitet.
In Georgia?
- Ja.
Aber deiner Familie
ging es gut nach dem Sturm?
Ja.
Und woher kennst du Zora?
Wir sind aus demselben Quartier.
Ich kenne Zora seit meiner Kindheit.
Von klein auf?
- Ja.
Bevor David als junger Mann
Puerto Rico verliess,
um in den USA als Schreiner
zu arbeiten,
hat er Bühnenbilder für Zora gemacht.
Jetzt, mit 58,
ist er zurück auf der Insel,
um sich um seine Eltern zu kümmern.
* Nachdenkliche Gitarrenmelodie *
So, Zora.
Sieht anders aus als gestern, oder?
- Si.
Bist du glücklich?
- Ich bin sehr glücklich.
Ich bin überrascht, was wir
in einem Tag alles geschafft haben.
Und ich bin sehr dankbar
für eure Arbeit.
Wenn man bedenkt, dass ihr
von der Schweiz hierherkommt,
zu Flor de Cahillo,
um uns zu helfen, uns zu motivieren.
Ihr sagt damit,
dass die Distanz keine Rolle spielt.
Wir sind eins,
es gibt nur einen Planeten.
Ja, wir sind alle eins.
Es ist immer noch viel Arbeit.
- Ja, viel Arbeit.
Manchmal
ist der Start das Wichtigste.
* Fröhliche Latino-Musik *
Es ist der 4. Juli,
der Nationalfeiertag,
an dem die USA ihre Unabhängigkeit
von der britischen Krone feiern.
Für mich eine gute Gelegenheit,
mehr über das Verhältnis
der Puerto Ricaner zu den
Vereinigten Staaten zu erfahren.
Also Beach statt Baustelle heute.
Hey, guys!
Hi, wir sind aus der Schweiz.
Wir machen einen Dokumentarfilm
über Puerto Rico.
Wie feiert ihr den 4. Juli?
Gut. Ganz toll.
- Yeah?
Und was macht ihr so an diesem Tag?
An den Strand gehen. Chillen.
- Ja, das sehe ich.
Hey, wie geht's euch? Frohen 4. Juli!
Wir drehen einen Dokumentarfilm.
Woher kommt ihr?
- Aus der Schweiz.
Schweiz? Krass.
Denkt ihr,
dass es auch euer Feiertag ist?
Nein.
- Warum nicht?
Wir sind ein Territorium,
kein Staat.
Fühlt ihr euch mehr
als Puerto Ricaner oder Amerikaner?
Oder als beides?
Ich bin stolz,
US-Amerikaner zu sein.
Ich habe in zwei Kriegen gekämpft.
Oh, du bist Veteran.
Ja, ich bin stolz,
Amerikaner zu sein,
aber ich bin auch stolz,
Puerto Ricaner zu sein.
Wir sind ein Zwischending.
Anstatt dazwischen zu sein,
wäre mir ein Staat lieber.
Also der 51. Bundesstaat?
- Yes.
Dann kann ich entscheiden,
wer Präsident wird.
Entweder ein Staat oder unabhängig.
Aber nicht die Situation jetzt.
Danke. War gut, mit euch zu reden.
"Puerto Rico se levanta":
Puerto Rico erhebt sich.
Was das heissen soll, darüber
gehen die Meinungen auseinander.
Die Vorstellungen reichen
von kompletter Integration
als Bundesstaat in den USA
bis zur vollständigen Unabhängigkeit.
Schon mehrmals
wurde darüber abgestimmt.
Zuletzt 2016, da war die Mehrheit
für den Bundesstaat.
Folgen haben solche Voten
allerdings keine:
Die Zukunft von Puerto Rico
wird in Washington bestimmt.
Und dort besteht wenig Interesse
daran, den Status quo zu ändern -
schliesslich würde jede Veränderung
auch einen Kontrollverlust bedeuten.
Kein Feuerwerk am Himmel
über San Juan am US-Nationalfeiertag.
Was wie ein politisches Statement
wirkt,
ist in Wahrheit aber nur
ein weiteres Zeichen dafür,
wie leer die Kassen hier sind.
Zora, was hältst du davon,
wenn wir gleich jetzt
ins Rathaus kommen,
um dich und die Bürgermeisterin
zu treffen?
Das ist eine gute Idee. Ich gehe
vor und rede mit ihrer Sekretärin.
Perfekt. Wir sehen uns da.
Bis jetzt waren sie ja vom puerto-
ricanischen Staat finanziert, oder?
Alles, was staatlich ist,
ist im Moment eigentlich bankrott.
Wegen des Sturms?
Nein, die Rezession
dauert schon elf Jahre.
Und mittlerweile hat der Staat
Schulden von 95 Mrd.
Das sind griechische Verhältnisse.
- Genau.
Obendrauf kam noch der Sturm. D.h.,
es ist jetzt kein Rappen mehr übrig.
Kriegt Zora nun das versprochene Geld
von der Bürgermeisterin
oder wird das Theater
weiter hingehalten?
Das ist die grosse Frage heute.
Da siehst du auch noch
ein blaues Dach vom Hurrikan.
Planen, hm?
Sogar im Stadthaus.
Ah, Zora, buenos dias!
- Que tal?
Bien, bien, bien. Y tu?
Zora, buenos dias.
Ich bin zufrieden.
Wir können zum Baumarkt gehen und
uns das Material schicken lassen.
Wir haben grünes Licht.
Hey, du kannst einkaufen gehen!
Let's go shopping!
Alright.
Tatsächlich: Die Bürgermeisterin
hat Zora 4'500 $ zugesagt.
Bedanken können wir uns
gleich persönlich, denn:
Jeden Morgen um 9 Uhr fährt ein Wagen
mit Lautsprecher vors Rathaus
und die Chefin tritt ans Fenster,
um für ihr Volk
die Stadthymne zu singen.
# Loiceno, has de marcar
en el tiempo el orgullo de tu honor.
# Tu vehemencia ha de encontrar luz
divina en horizontes de alta mar.
Danke für das Geld für das Theater.
Thanks for the credit. Thanks.
Tag 4 auf unserer Baustelle.
* Erschrockener Aufschrei *
* Unverständlicher Wortwechsel
auf Spanisch *
Heute sind ein paar Jugendliche
dazugekommen, die mithelfen.
Sie alle standen hier
auch mal auf der Bühne.
Der Hurrikan hat das Gebäude
von der Versorgung abgeschnitten.
Nun geht es aber auch da vorwärts:
Das Team kümmert sich
um die kaputte Wasserleitung.
Sollen wir das Wasser testen?
- Water?
Poco testo. Water.
Wir haben das Rohr repariert.
Is it coming?
- Wasser! Das will ich sehen.
* Überraschtes Einatmen *
Si!
Sale agua!
Agua, agua, agua!
Auch Alex,
der den kleinen Guancho gespielt hat,
kommt heute auf die Baustelle.
Wie fühlst du dich,
wenn du das Theater so siehst?
Schlecht.
Es ist unglaublich,
was die Natur anrichten kann.
Wenn etwas kaputt geht, muss man es
immer wieder aufbauen. Noch stärker.
Das muss man.
Ich habe gelernt,
dass alles von einem selbst abhängt.
Du musst dir selbst
ein besseres Leben geben.
Du weisst schon viel.
Wird der Kleine zurückkommen,
wenn das Theater wieder steht?
Ja, das ist die Idee.
Manchmal ist Geld nicht alles.
Manchmal braucht man
eine helfende, liebende Hand.
Das möchte ich ihm beibringen.
Das ist eine gute Lektion.
Wendy, die Mutter von Alex,
lebte auch ein paar Jahre in den USA
und hat sich dann
für Puerto Rico entschieden.
Denkst du, es ist gut,
dass du sowohl hier
als auch in den Staaten leben kannst?
Ja. Wir haben das Beste
aus beiden Welten.
Ich kann in Puerto Rico leben,
aber ich habe trotzdem die Freiheit,
jederzeit in die USA zu gehen
und dort mein Glück zu suchen.
In den USA klopft aber niemand an
deine Tür und sagt: "Ich helfe dir."
Hier in Puerto Rico
ist es ein wenig einfacher,
sich irgendwie durchzuwursteln -
ich mag das nicht so.
In den USA muss man hart arbeiten,
um überleben zu können.
Ja, nicht erwarten,
dass andere dir helfen.
Sicher nicht Donald Trump.
Er ist nur eine Person.
Wir sind mehr.
Er kann noch 50 Jahre im Amt sein,
wir sind grösser.
Die USA und auch Puerto Rico werden
nicht wegen Donald Trump untergehen.
Du hast
eine gute positive Einstellung.
Danke.
Stichwort Trump.
Er hat sich auf Puerto Rico
wenig Freunde gemacht nach dem Sturm:
Die Hilfe lief nur zögerlich an,
erst nach fast zwei Wochen kam
der Präsident selber auf die Insel -
und warf, um seine Hilfsbereitschaft
zu unterstreichen,
Haushaltspapier in die Menge.
* Treibende Klänge *
Ein Schlag ins Gesicht
für die Menschen hier,
besonders auch
für die Bürgermeisterin von San Juan,
die damals klare Worte fand:
Diese Frau muss ich kennenlernen.
Ihr Schlagabtausch mit Trump machte
Carmen Yulin international bekannt.
Das "Time Magazine"
zählte sie danach zu den 100
einflussreichsten Personen der Welt.
Buenas tardes.
Ah, Sie sprechen spanisch.
Sie sind Puerto Ricanerin.
Ich freue mich, Sie kennenzulernen.
Ich bin der Schweizer.
Good to see you.
Gutes Land, gute Leute,
gute Schokolade.
Thank you.
Danke, dass Sie sich Zeit nehmen.
- Don't worry.
Kameramann Sergio.
- Tolle Augen!
Carmen Yulin
möchte uns einen Park zeigen,
den sie renovieren liess -
ihr Paradeprojekt in San Juan.
Per solarbetriebenem Minibus
geht's darum erst mal auf Rundfahrt,
mit einer Bürgermeisterin
zum Anfassen, wie wir schnell merken.
Son de una emision
de un pais que se llama Suiza.
Wie sagt man "Hallo" auf Deutsch?
- Grüezi.
Griezi?
Es muy dificil, verdad? Griezi.
Digale "hola"! Una, dos y tres.
- (Alle) Hola!
Vengan mas cerca!
Una, dos y tres!
Danke, dass Sie für uns kämpfen.
- Das werde ich immer.
Ich kämpfe, sie schlagen mich,
und ich kämpfe weiter.
(Kinder im Chor) Adios!
Etwas vom Wichtigsten im Park
ist unser Gewächshaus.
Alle Angestellten hier
sind schwere Autisten.
Wir wollen eine Gesellschaft bilden,
in der jeder etwas beitragen kann.
Es spielt keine Rolle,
ob du nur etwas kannst,
wie z.B. Samen pflanzen.
Man sieht es mir nicht an,
aber ich bin Legasthenikerin,
darum trage ich all diese Armbänder.
Als ich klein war,
bemerkte meine Kindergärtnerin,
dass ich leicht verwirrt wurde.
Sie band mir einen Gummi
um die rechte Hand,
damit ich sie von meiner linken
unterscheiden konnte.
Mittlerweile
hat jedes Band eine Bedeutung.
Dieses hier
bekam ich als Auszeichnung dafür,
dass ich Wahrheiten ausspreche.
Ist das zu glauben?
- Dafür gibt es eine Auszeichnung?
Wenn man jemanden dafür auszeichnen
muss, die Wahrheit zu sagen -
ich meine - das sagt schon etwas
über unsere politische Klasse, oder?
Vielleicht
sollten wir uns irgendwo hinsetzen.
Ja, gut.
Aha, Sie sind so einer.
- So einer?
Mit einem Notizbuch.
Ja, ich schreibe die Dinge gern auf.
Mit mir geht sie sehr locker um -
nicht aber mit Washington.
Sie spricht jenen Puerto Ricanern
aus der Seele,
die sich im Stich gelassen fühlen.
Sie sagten, dass Puerto Ricaner
wie Bürger zweiter Klasse
behandelt werden.
Nun, wir sind eine Kolonie der USA.
Wir tragen Fesseln und sind uns
dessen nicht einmal bewusst.
Ich glaube,
das nennt man Stockholm-Syndrom:
Du merkst gar nicht,
dass du keine eigenständigen
Entscheidungen treffen kannst.
Es gibt ein Aufsichtsgremium,
das jetzt über den Kopf
von Puerto Ricos Gouverneur
Finanzentscheide fällt.
Manche denken, dass wir uns
in einem Machtkampf befinden.
Ich denke das nicht.
Ich weiss, wer an der Macht ist -
und es sind nicht wir.
Was wir brauchen, ist ein richtiger
demokratischer Dialog:
Okay, sagt uns, USA,
was braucht es, damit ihr uns
einen Bundesstaat gebt?
Was,
damit ihr uns Unabhängigkeit gebt?
Was für ein freies Bündnis
mit doppelter Staatsbürgerschaft?
Oder für eine Erweiterung
des heutigen Status?
Lasst die Bürger entscheiden!
Thanks again.
- Thank you.
Thanks for coming.
Eine Frau ohne Berührungsängste -
und ohne Angst vor Grossmächten.
Von dieser Politikerin
wird man, denke ich, noch hören.
Sie überlegt sich, für ein nationales
Amt ins Rennen zu steigen.
Es ist Tag 5 auf der Baustelle.
"Schöner Wohnen" in Loiza,
Puerto Rico.
Das Material, das Zora mit dem Geld
der Gemeinde gekauft hat,
wird geliefert.
Das hier werden die Bretter sein,
die die Welt bedeuten
für viele kleine Tänzerinnen
in Loiza.
Wir beeilen uns,
denn für morgen schon
hat Zora eine erste
kleine Vorstellung geplant,
als Abschiedsfest für uns.
Und weil ich jetzt mehr als einmal
dazu aufgefordert wurde,
wage ich mich auch noch
auf die traditionellen Stelzen.
Der Stelzenläufer,
der sog. Vejigante,
ist eine zentrale Figur
in Puerto Ricos Folklore.
I have a flashback from my horse.
Zoras Tochter Rosia zeigt mir,
wie es geht.
Okay, number two. Got it.
Ich erklär dir, was du tun musst.
Du musst deine Beine stabil halten.
Und was passiert,
wenn ich runterfalle?
Dafür gibt es Techniken.
Aber du wirst nicht fallen.
Du kannst dich zum Balancieren
am Gitter festhalten.
Jede Menge Vertrauen hier.
I got it.
Du musst balancieren.
Wenn du das da wegschiebst,
kann ich da laufen.
Jetzt laufe ich zu der Tür da.
- Okay.
Wow. Good.
Du balancierst gut.
Und zurück.
Machst du das zum ersten Mal?
- Ja.
Wow!
Weiss nicht. Snowboarden und Skate-
boarden braucht auch viel Balance.
So I think I got ...
* Die Frauen trällern ein Lied
auf Spanisch. *
Thank you. You're a good teacher.
Good swinging.
Ich ahne es: Morgen muss ich wohl
selber auch auf die Bühne.
Das kann ja heiter werden.
(Navigationsgerät)
Gira a la izquierda
para continuar por Puerto Rico 686.
* Fröhlicher Latin-Pop *
Weisst du, was toll ist
an Puerto Rico? Überall Musik.
Überall.
Jeder bringt seine eigene Musik
und zusammen
ergibt es diesen speziellen Sound.
Schau, man kann die Stadt sehen!
- Yeah.
Wo sollen wir hin?
David hat die ganze Woche
fast pausenlos gearbeitet.
Zum Abschluss lade ich ihn
auf ein Feierabendbier ein.
Ich mache das, weil ich Zora liebe.
Sie ist wie meine Schwester.
Wenn sie mich braucht, bin ich da.
Denkst du, du gehst jemals zurück
in die Staaten?
Ich denke nicht.
Vielleicht gehe ich mal auf Besuch.
Meine Tochter und mein Enkel
leben in Georgia.
Ich möchte hier bleiben. Es reicht.
Ich bin müde vom Herumreisen.
Ich liebe meine Insel.
Das ist mein Paradies.
It sure is.
- Puerto Rico.
Man könnte meinen, dass der Sturm
alles zerstört hat.
Er hat auch viel zerstört,
aber nicht den Geist.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Die Energie hier beeindruckt mich:
fast trotzig weitermachen,
auch wenn so viel in Trümmern liegt.
Mit diesem Gedanken wache ich auf
an meinem letzten Tag auf der Insel.
Wir haben viel geschafft
auf der Baustelle:
Das Dach
ist zwar noch nicht wieder ganz,
aber der Boden ist gelegt,
und der ist beim Tanzen
ja das Wichtigste.
Look at this!
Jetzt sieht's aus wie ein Theater.
Hey!
Bis zuletzt tun David und Zora alles,
um die Bühne herauszuputzen.
Die Strapazen der letzten Tage aber
haben Spuren hinterlassen.
Auf der einen Seite
bin ich sehr dankbar und zufrieden,
weil wir viel erreicht haben,
obwohl wir wenige waren.
Andererseits - wenn ich wenige sage,
dann meine ich wenige.
Ich fühle ich mich
auch etwas im Stich gelassen.
Von den Leuten, die gesagt haben,
dass sie kommen,
ist kaum jemand aufgetaucht.
Trotzdem hat Zora noch die Energie,
in ganz Loiza herumzufahren,
um Kinder für den heutigen Auftritt
einzusammeln.
Wie viele hast du jetzt? Fünf?
- Vier.
Okay. Fünf. Hola! Und sechs.
Nicole. Y ella es Adriana.
- Nicole and Adriana.
Das sind sehr gute Schauspielerinnen
und Tänzerinnen.
Okay.
- Si.
Auch ein Profi-Vejigante
macht sich bereit.
Bei dem kann ich mir ja vielleicht
noch ein paar Tricks abschauen.
Die Aufführung heute
ist eine exklusive Kostprobe dessen,
was die Kinder hier
alles gelernt haben.
Zum Auftakt sehen wir gleich einen
typisch puerto-ricanischen Tanz.
Beim Bomba
handelt es sich um einen Wettbewerb
zwischen den Trommlern
und der Tänzerin.
Sie gibt eine Bewegung vor,
und er muss darauf reagieren.
Wenn er keine Antwort
auf ihre Herausforderung hat,
ist er raus und muss aufstehen.
Wenn sie nicht mehr nachkommt,
weil sie sich verliert,
dann hat sie verloren
und zieht sich zurück.
* Fröhliches Lied
mit Trommelbegleitung *
* Der Trommler
wechselt den Rhythmus. *
Echt beeindruckend,
was die Kleinen hier schon können.
Jetzt verstehe ich auch,
dass Zoras Theater
auch mehr ist als ein Sozialprojekt:
Es ist ein lebendiges Stück
lokaler Kultur.
Dieser Rhythmus
wirkt wie ein musikalischer Magnet.
Da tanzen
dann auch Schweizer Füsse mit.
* Rasantes Trommeln *
That was great. Thank you.
Und ja: die Stelzen.
Davor kann ich mich jetzt
nicht drücken.
Ich bin schon etwas aufgeregt, aber
hey: Auch das ist eine Erfahrung.
Ich spüre, wie wichtig es
den Menschen hier war,
dass nach Maria auch eine andere
Seite von Puerto Rico gezeigt wird -
und wie die Insel
wieder auf die Beine kommt.
Just always keep moving.
- Yeah!
* Lautes Pfeifen *
Alright.
* Er trällert eine Melodie. *
Monate später erhalte ich
eine erfreuliche Nachricht:
Lisa Ladner hat
eine Schweizer Stiftung gefunden,
die dem Theater unter die Arme greift
und Flor de Cahillo
so eine Zukunft schenkt.